so hat
[Musik]
was erlebt eine auf einer reise von
20.000 kilometern entlang der
panamericana auf den spuren der freiheit
und dem kontinent der unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten
die start am nördlichsten punkt der usa
in alaska
wainwright ein walfänger dorf rosa
wahlkreis liegt im schnee und die banken
des basars
[Musik]
meine reise führt mich von alaska nach
argentinien zwei kontinente zehn länder
eine straße die legendäre panamericana
von den inuit im eis bis zu den gauchos
in der baumbach
80 jahre lebenserfahrung und ein
benzinmotor brettern durch das dorf war
von captain peacock ist die autorität in
wainwright sein ganzes leben verbrachte
hier außer seiner jahre als soldat in
vietnam
talk ist einer der letzten der die
sprache der ureinwohner spricht genug
york was heißt das dorf lebt von der
jagd vom walfang und den subventionen
der usa durchschnittliche
jahrestemperatur minus fünf grad statt
in iglus wohnen die inuit in
blockhäusern mit satelliten-tv petersohn
brutzelt ein stück walfisch auf dem
elektroherd
[Musik]
eigentlich hatte die regierung den
walfang verboten
doch nach protesten der walfang dörfer
gilt heute eine quote von 7 walen pro
jahr und dorf aus höflichkeit müsste ich
ein stück probieren doch ich passe decke
hoch ist mir einfach zu streng
die talk und sein sohn nehmen mich mit
auf eine andere jagt
sie haben außerhalb des dorfes karibus
gesichtet schnee herrsche das ist kein
sport sondern wichtige
nahrungsbeschaffung für die ureinwohner
die ein bescheidenes leben führen
[Musik]
ich kann kaum glauben dass hier schnee
hirsch überleben doch diese finden
tatsächlich in tausenden schnee genügend
gras
[Musik]
oliver hat eine herde gesichtet
er legt an und schießt betrifft eine
hirschkuh
stock ist wie alle immac praktisch
nichts aus fleisch und fett
trotzdem gelten die inuit auch sehr
gesund die hirschkuh gibt wenig her
es ist ende winter die tiere sind
abgemagert schlecht in dieser jahreszeit
wir brauchen es nicht
du kannst die haare sehr leicht
ausreißen im herbst gibt dickerer fälle
die behalten nun ist die jagd bedroht
denn nur 500 kilometer entfernt liegen
die größten ölvorkommen nordamerikas das
in einem jahr auch hier in wayne wright
gebohrt werden soll
beunruhigt die inuit andererseits leben
wir in einer zeit in der wir arbeiten
und arbeit gibt es wenig in form bringt
viele jobs ins dorf
[Musik]
so leben die nicht abgeschieden aber
nicht abgenommen
sie brachen benzin für ihre motoren
besprechen den walfänger facebook und
wollen für immer hier bleiben denn eines
home sie freiheit
[Musik]
und so wie ich gekommen bin verlasse ich
bereits mit einem kleinen flugzeug
und schon zwei stunden später treffe ich
auf ein bekanntes amerika big business
die ölfelder von proto bay
gerne würde ich hier die kontroverse um
mehr ölförderung in alaska verfolgen
doch ein zutritt zu den bohrfeldern
bleibt mir strikte verwehrt von einer
transportfirma halte ich den namen eines
trockners der mich richtung süden
mitnimmt ich bin kein motorrad bedauert
dass präsident obama sein veto gegen
weitere bohrungen eingelegt hat er hätte
gerne billigeren diesen
[Musik]
auf dem datenhighway geht die reise
weiter
es ist das erste straßenstück der
panamericana eine der einsamsten
strecken der usa
[Musik]
arktische tundra die 1300 kilometer
lange pipeline und manchmal eindruck
dass der norden alaskas
[Musik]
eigentlich wäre ich gerne noch lange so
weiter gefahren doch ich habe einen
termin mit jamie
sie und ihr bruder tyler betreiben eine
lodge für abenteuer touristen natürlich
ist sie nur mit dem flugzeug zu
erreichen wie so oft in alaska
[Musik]
sie haben das unternehmen vom vater
geerbt der vor zwei jahren gestorben ist
[Musik]
die geschwister wuchsen eigentlich
weiter südlich auf
doch auch sie sind im norden alaskas
verfahren
ich liebe das gefühl der freiheit in der
luft ohne probleme werden ganz klein
und es bringt nicht mehr zu meinem vater
[Musik]
in gewisser weise ist es wie bei den
inuit kein rummel nichts aus weiter
[Musik]
bettels ist die provinz der provinz 63
einwohner einladen eine post drei
straßen jamie war bürgermeisterin
sie betreibt die lodge und ist yoga
lehrerin seit ein paar jahren ist wenn
der wichtigste mann in ihrem leben als
süße schlittenhunde und fährt rennen
seine heimat ist nicht alaska und liegt
alles andere aus um die ecke hand von
kollegin nicole aufregend wenn wir den
zugang im onkologie und verlags kapital
und dann bin ich für sechs männer so
richtig was mich so richtig rein sorgen
und dann passierte was die ist die ehe
zu gehen
damit wird beschrieben ist aber dass
freiheit durch lätta honda team mit 16
trainierten wo quasi meine hände flach
dass ein sehr schöner nachmittag schon
beschrieben
[Musik]
nachts um halb zwölf wenn die
mitternachtssonne sich über den horizont
senkt setzten sich sven der appenzeller
und jamie vor ihr haus
zehn jahre ist es her seit sie sich
genau hier kennen lernten
er kann einfach eines tages den fluss
herunter gesprochen ich war an praktisch
in inge und eine gruppe schweizer hinein
die ihren rechten waren seither ist klar
dass sie ihre zukunft gemeinsam
verbringen möchten
da stellt sich noch eine große frage ist
doch gut zusammen
die hatte das paar süße kleine appenzell
alaska baby nur wenig dafür ein paar
monate in der schweiz
[Gelächter]
morris james 30 es bleibt also noch
etwas zeit
[Musik]
wenn die schlittenhunde einen tierarzt
brachen oder ein rennen bestreiten
fliegt wenn sie mit dem flugzeug
dieses mal geht es nach fairbanks sven
quandt eine gletschertour im süden die
hunde werden in kleinen gruppen
transportiert kann ich nur kontrolliere
wenn das leben nach wie vor miteinander
für reibereien nicht einmal dann wenn es
denn so achten
die hunde seien gerne im flugzeug
solange meister dabei sei sagt sven
[Musik]
und so fliegen sie richtung süden
während ich alaska mit wehmut verlassen
mein nächstes ziel ist ettlin kanada
[Musik]
mit dem zug geht die reise weiter über
den weit es vor etwas mehr als 100
jahren benutzten die goldsucher diesen
zug auf ihrem weg an den yukon und den
klondike river sehr viel schneller aus
vor 100 jahren bewegt sich der zug heute
nicht darf seiner fahrt über die grenze
nach kanada
[Musik]
es ist eine reise in die vergangenheit
noch immer stehen die blockhütten der
goldsucher verlassen da das letzte stück
mit dem auto vor bayern unendlichen
wäldern und schneebedeckten gipfeln und
wenn man glück hat wilden tieren
es sind grizzlybären eine mutter und
zwei junge von den athos lassen sie sich
nicht stören
ein klarer kalter morgen in atlanta
goldgräberstadt
es ist mai gerade das eis saison beginnt
für goldsucher golfspielen und gold
suchen von smallwood tut endlich was er
schon immer wollte
ron ist pensioniert und verbringt seine
ferien in der goldmine eines freundes
abends wenn die bagger still stehen sagt
mister smallwood nach seinem glück fast
so wie damals als er noch börsenhändler
war die machte suche nach einem guten
deal sieben tagen mein erster 529
nuggets am selben fleck
ach komm schon das team war nicht ich
trage sie immer bei mir
ich habe geschrien gold aber niemand
hörte es
konventionen interessieren rang nicht
mehr
er genießt seine leidenschaft dazu
gehört das camp ihren zwischen rost und
starb und die zeit für seine frau warum
geht ihr nicht dabei diese wunderschönen
campingplätze ganz in der nähe am see
statt ihren dreck die haben nicht die
atmosphäre wie hier
ich mag keine organisierten
campingplätze da hätten alle aufeinander
ich möchte auch er einer der die weite
und die freiheit des nordens gefunden
hat an einem feuer im yukon
[Musik]
peter dettling zeigt mehr sein stück
freiheit dass er hier gesucht hat der
bündner wurde seine heimat zu eng und so
lebt der seit zehn jahren in den
kanadischen rocky mountains dettling
vermisst seine heimat
aber der gedanke hier in kanada das
letzte paradies zu finden ließ ihm keine
ruhe
heute ist er einer der renommiertesten
tierfotografen kanadas es ist morgens um
sechs peter nimmt mich mit darf eine
fotosafari erhofft so früh am morgen
bären zu treffen
und tatsächlich
das ist schön dass wir mal ganz für die
hofstatt der auftrennung möglichkeit das
was wir wirklich geniessen über die
vegetation der zumindest hofstaat und
ganz gern dirk ströer und so war sie
davon gesprochen
das ist ein paradies das seine unschuld
noch nicht verloren hat
irgendwann stellte peter fest dass er
sich täuschte mitten durch den banff
national park führen eine hauptstraße
und eine eisenbahnlinie
pro jahr werden mehrere hundert tiere
überfahren
der zufall will es dass gerade jetzt
drei schwarzbären die gleise überqueren
einige minuten später folgt ein güterzug
die bären haben es gerade noch geschafft
oft kommt der wird überrascht und den
worten davor erinnern und um 3 und
durfte gleich wie das alles frei sind
worte der vorräte und dazu kommt das
paradies hat peter in kanada nicht
gefunden aber mit seinen bildern kämpft
er dafür dass es nicht noch mehr
zerstört wird
[Musik]
ruhe und frieden einige tage später in
der kanadischen prärie treffe ich
menschen die nichts anderes suchen
weitab liegt die gemeinde der mutter
es sind täufer nachfahren von your
computer und ursprünglich tiroler der
patriarch führt die gemeinde streng nach
der bibel
monatelang hat es nur geregnet
sintflutartig und gerechte gott auch er
weiß was er tut
aber dann sollte es nicht so wegen was
meiner meinung nach sollten nicht so
regnen 8
[Gelächter]
fast 500 gemeinden existieren in kanada
und den usa
alles in der bibel nehmen sie wörtlich
wegen ihres glaubens wurden die mutter
oft vertrieben nach osteuropa und
amerika doch ihre tiroler wurzeln sind
lebendig das zeigt mir sam's tochter eva
wahrscheinlich sind es die alten dinge
die es seit ewig gibt das sind heute
rischer wörter
in vielen bereichen leben männer und
frauen für sich die nutzerinnen
erledigen die klassischen aufgaben
kochen waschen kinder erziehen
im speisesaal wird nach geschlechtern
getrennt gegessen
[Musik]
fast alles gehört den hut daran
gemeinsam
ausgenommen sind nur wenige private
dinge ich trage eine armbanduhr
ehrlich gesagt ich hatte einen ring
machte mich zu stolz also entschloss ich
mich ihnen nicht zu tragen weil ich
freilich sei zu stolz auf diesen ring
nicht stolz sein
nein stolz ist eine form von gier
christus will nicht dass wir stolz sind
nicht den persönlichen dingen
auf bauern- und tierzüchter sind die
hydra sehr erfolgreich sie gelten aus
zuverlässige lieferanten in der gemeinde
fällt niemand aus dem sozialen netz
arbeitslosigkeit ist ein fremdwort
die stimmung beim abpacken der truthähne
ist fast übermütig aber schließlich ist
es einfach arbeit
wie gefällt euch die arbeit
[Musik]
das beste ist wenn wir heimkommen
als sam die kolonie ins leben rief waren
sie eine kleine gruppe heute leben 120
entdecker langsam aber sicher sind es zu
viele
eine ihrer grundsätze lautet mit viel
mehr als 100 leuten kannst du nicht gut
zusammen leben
deshalb muss wohl ein teil der jungen
losziehen und eine eigene gemeinde
bilden
[Musik]
gezügelt durch strenge gesetze so fühle
ich mich bei dem hydra aber auch ruhig
und aufgehoben
eine seltsame freiheit sie irgendwo aus
dem innern kommt
[Musik]
und so nehme ich abschied von kanada und
fahrer über die grenze in die usa
yellowstone nationalpark ein blick auf
die letzten wilden bisons in drei tagen
will ich in kalifornien sein
dem einzigen inbegriff der bundes
grenzen möglichkeiten
das wahrzeichen dafür ist die golden
gate brücke in san francisco aus sie
gebaut wurde existierte er noch der
amerikanische traum mitte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts im
kalifornischen goldrausch war dies das
tor zu reichtum und glück
[Musik]
heute ist kalifornien schwer verschuldet
jeder zehnte arbeitslos doch san
francisco verströmt eine ungebrochene
anziehungskraft
[Musik]
1968 revolution 2012 noch immer ein
lebens labor silicon valley genies
schwule außenseiter filmstars geldadel
und good vibrations
ich habe einen prominenten führer den
comedian comeback
er kam aus der provinz nach san
francisco und zeigt mir seine stadt das
ist eben das regele dass ich erwähnt das
braucht es damit die stadt sogleich es
könnte die abschlussarbeiten die
studenten sagen wir können hier durch
eine doktorarbeit gehen wir schauen es
an wir bewundern ist
in san francisco spielen die schwarzen
nur eine nebenrolle
kammer nimmt mich mit den seine
lieblings buchhandlung
bell wuchs ohne vater auf seine mutter
gab ihm den kenianischen namen kam
sie verlangte von ihm dass er stolz sei
auf die geschichte der schwarzen in den
usa
hier sucht er sich die themen für sein
bühnenprogramm das sich meist um
schwarze identität dreht noch immer sagt
bell seien sie in den usa benachteiligt
aber es gibt 450 schwarze bürgermeister
in amerika ihr habt einen schwarzen
präsidenten ihr seid doch
gleichberechtigt gleichberechtigt ja
natürlich
was reden wir denn dummerweise geht das
nicht einfach über nacht
das braucht zeit diese leute sind die
söhne und töchter von sklaven und kommen
von einer tieferen sozialen schicht sie
sind immer noch benachteiligt weil die
schulen in der innenstadt schlechter
sind die jobangebote in schlechter sind
und das bist du immer zur unterricht auf
der leiter abends in kammern bis comedy
programm
das thema ist die hautfarbe von barack
obama 18 die amerikaner glauben barack
obama sei ein muslim
das glauben sie nicht wirklich sagen das
nur weil sie nicht sagen dürfen
und so kämpft cambell mit humor für
seine sache und weiß es ist nicht alles
gold was glänzt
[Musik]
so ist amerika niemals regnet es in
kalifornien immer scheint die sonne auf
dem highway one außer man ist gerade
selber unterwegs in einem cabrio die
suche nach dem amerikanischen traum im
dicken nebel richtung süden
aus sicht der nebel lichtet gibt den
blick frei auf ein skateboarder da meine
neugierde weckt
ich bin schon diskutiert du machst witze
wie lange wie es unterwegs
heute sind es drei wochen und vier tage
wie kamst du auf
ich würde man quer durch amerika skaten
mein fahrer sagt er mache es für einen
guten zweck
ich sammle für ein christliches
obdachlosenheim
das ist für dich du bist ein super typ
danke es ist für frauen und kinder ohne
dach überm kopf
ich habe mir in meinem rucksack als
seine ganze familie mit chandler 18
jahre alt und voller ideale er lebt
seinen amerikanischen traum
ich verlasse die küste und mache einen
abstecher nach ford lake city utah
unabhängigkeit und freiheit hier werden
sie mit waffen verteidigt der start der
mormonen hat eines der liberalsten
waffengesetze der usa das angebot an
gewehren pistolen und revolvern ist
riesig es sei besser wenn die waffen in
den händen der bürger seien aus in denen
der mächtigen sagen mir die kunden und
manchmal vermischen sich die grenzen
zwischen waffe und modisches accessoire
im waffenladen angeschlossen ist ein
schießkeller
wer noch keinen waffenschein hat kann
ihn hier erwerben
ich zweifle aber mit der verbreitung der
waffen die sicherheit steigt
spüren sie adrenalin
ich habe drei treffer und so wollen sie
sich selbst verteidigen wenn ich muss um
meine familie zu retten
sie würden nie jemanden erschießen
ja für meine familie absolut
nicht jeder der schießen will muss in
utah in den waffen keller
solange er die verantwortung übernimmt
darf ein schütze auch im freien üben mit
einigen waffennarren aus im schießkeller
fahre ich an den utah weg etwas
außerhalb der stadt
1 schieß instruktor zeigte neulingen wie
man mit besonders potenten waffen umgeht
erklärt die munition und warnt davor in
der schusslinie zu stehen es lebe die
freiheit und die amerikanische tradition
das ist spielt den cowboys und indianer
im wald größere jungs größere
spielsachen so einfach ist das und diese
in ziemlich teuer
[Gelächter]
es braucht die volle konzentration
du vergisst alles um dich rum
es ist sehr befriedigend das ziel zu
treffen
in der einen hand die waffe in der
anderen die bibel so zogen die mormonen
hierher
daran scheint sich in utah wenig
geändert zu haben
weiter südlich lag früher amerikas
wilder westen
mein nächstes ziel ist der jazz national
park in colorado nach einem heftigen
regen zeigen sich die ersten vorzeichen
im roten abendlicht
die sterne für einen schönen neuen tag
stehen gut
[Musik]
panamericana heißt ganz amerika und
verheißt begegnungen mit menschen und
landschaften
und images national park ist eine
begegnung mit den letzten 100 millionen
erden jahren
2000 brücken und bürger sandstein
entstanden durch erosion wasser und eis
[Musik]
das ist mehr als eine landschaft das ist
eine begehbare galerie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
beinahe wäre ich vorbei gefahren da sehe
ich einen alten laden als den zeiten des
wilden westens einsam steht er da weit
und breit niemand zu sehen offenbar ist
er zu verkaufen
ich hoffe es dauert eine weile dann
öffnet sich die tür und die rund timber
groß erzählt mir dass ihr laden aus dem
jahr 1881 stammt einer der ältesten in
ganz kanada
als ich das haus sah dachte ich zuerst
an ein museum
und tatsächlich ist das nicht weit
hergeholt
das ist von 1917 mit dem oberen balkon
herr wird die straßen haben sich
verändert
ich habe das gefühl niemand hat die
karte herausgenommen ich habe angst dass
sie auseinander fällt
so was tun sie mit all den dingen ist es
dabei wenn man das haus ja außer der
preis ist zu tief
wie viel kostet das haus jetzt 395.000
dollar
ein stolzer preis für ein stück
nostalgie us open house
[Musik]
roche muss ihr geschäft wegen einer
krankheit verkaufen
ich hoffe dass sie einen guten käufer
findet und so verlasse ich den
klassischen südwesten amerikas
[Musik]
von bedrock colorado reise ich weiter
nach süden in die mitte mexikos nach
mittelamerika dem scharnier zum süden
[Musik]
ich habe flugzeuge benutzt züge und
autos und jetzt wo land und leute mit
weniger auskommen müssen ändert sich
nach der reise stil
während die einen das pferd benutzen
bieten wir einige bauern einen platz an
auf ihren pick up
[Musik]
lateinamerikanische lebensfreude das ist
die eine seite mexikos eine andere
realität ist mexikos transit land
honduras nicaragua oder guatemala
strömen die armen gegen norden mit dem
ziel ihr glück in den usa zu finden
ich bedanke mich für die
mitfahrgelegenheit mit etwas geld fürs
benzin die meisten leute tanken nur
gerade so viel wie sie für die nächste
fahrt brauchen
an einer tankstelle in akkuyu kann
treffe ich die mitarbeiter der gruppe
peter
eine staatliche organisation die
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge aus dem süden auf
ihrer odyssee mit nothilfe unterstützt
oskar und seine leute
nimm mich mit auf ihre tägliche tour
[Musik]
weiter der gruppe ein soziologe ist den
migranten gegenüber milde gestimmt
[Musik]
migranten sind freunde die arbeit suchen
was können sie arbeiten oder sie illegal
hier sehe ich das hier schwer in mexiko
wir versuchen sie davon abzuhalten dass
sie sich weiter in die usa durchschlage
es wäre besser wenn sie nach hause
zurück geben hier im niemandsland liegt
einer der brennpunkte eines globalen
phänomens media saß ein güterbahnhof kam
kommen wir an treffen wir eine gruppe
von flüchtlingen
august joas honduras 14 jahre schlug er
sich als maler in den usa durch dann
machte ihm das schicksal einen strich
durch die rechnung
warum sind sie nicht mehr da eigentlich
illegal dort war sie haben nicht
ausgeschafft
jetzt versuche ich es wieder ja haben
sie jetzt papiere
nein warum versuchen sie es nochmals
weil ich geld brauche
geld und arbeit franziska ramirez aus
nicaragua
ich habe sind die kleider die schuhe und
die wäsche zum wechseln wenn die andere
schmutzig zweier woche hält ein güterzug
in medias argus auf seinem weg bis an
die grenze der usa
der zug der hoffnung der eigentlich
todeszug heißt zwar immer wieder blinde
passagier after fahrt verunglücken oder
sogar umgebracht werden
und sollten sie es tatsächlich bis an
die amerikanische grenze schaffen
schickt die polizei zehntausende von
ihnen zurück nur ein bruchteil wird
erfolgreich sein illegal mit einer
höchst unsicheren zukunft
ihr wisst dass es besser wäre zu ihren
familien zurückzukehren
sie wissen ist natürlich aber es spielt
keine rolle wir wissen dass es schwer
ist ohne papiere in die usa zu kommen
aber das ist der traum von jedem aus
mittelamerika in dieses land zu gelangen
und einen besseres leben zu haben
auch für unsere familien es bleibt immer
ein traum denn mit der armut in unserem
land ist es auf jeden fall einer
verbesserung
und so gehen sie zu fuß bis zum zug der
sie ihrem traum ein stück näher bringen
soll
[Musik]
zweimal pro woche wird das media sag was
sein schauplatz bedrückender schicksale
und wenn der zug wieder fort ist wird
das dorf wieder was es eigentlich war
ein verschlafenes nest verloren in der
zeit
[Musik]
ich verlasse das spanisch geprägte
mexiko und reise nach panama in den
regenwald hier lebt einer der größten
indianerstämme von panama und kolumbien
hier treffe ich meine begleiterin andy
mit einem indianer verheiratet ist
[Musik]
viel mehr noch als ein umstrittener
finanzplatz ist panama ein naturparadies
als stränden und urwald
finde ich der bewohner des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts hier noch
ein stück um verdorbenes leben
[Musik]
ankunft im dorf bourg en führt mich bei
ihrer familie ein auf den ersten blick
hat sich am leben der indianer wenig
geändert wie seit jahren tag leben sie
von der jagd dem fischfang und dem
gemüse anbauen kann per zufall ins dorf
sie arbeitete aus tiertrainerin für den
film vor sieben jahren war sie hier bei
dreharbeiten dabei das veränderte ihr
leben
einer der männer interessierte sich für
mich und wir verbrachten zeit zusammen
dann lud er mich ein seine eltern kennen
zu lernen und diese waren unglaublich
nett und offen
jetzt gehören sie ganz dazu ja sie
nämlich anderer verena touren weiße mbh
frei das ensi schnell akzeptiert wurde
mag ein zeichen dafür sein dass die mba
schon lange regen austausch mit der
außenwelt pflegen eine zweischneidige
sache wieder häuptling mir erklärt
natürlich leben wir nicht mehr so wie
früher die motoren für die boote sind
zwar bequem aber nicht unbedingt
notwendig die kosten auch geld das wir
jetzt verdienen müssen
dafür können wir in der stadt mit dem
handy telefonieren
das hilft uns in einem notfall oder wenn
verwandte von weither auf besuch kommen
[Musik]
in den letzten 20 jahren erklärte panama
viele dschungelgebiete zu nationalparks
auch das gebiet der mr seither ist es
ihnen kaum mehr erlaubt zu jagen oder
bäume zu fällen
die indianer müssen lernen wie sie ihre
kultur in form von kunsthandwerk zu geld
machen können
geschickt verkaufen sie es an die
abenteuer touristen die immer öfter das
dorf besuchen
ich bin überrascht wie entspannt sie
damit umgehen wenn die asiaten stammt
lebt heute zur hälfte in panama city und
die andere zeit mehr oder weniger
angepasst im dorf kuru es die impera
nicht dass sie kleider tragen naja sie
wissen dass ich aus einer anderen kultur
kommen aber sie haben auch kein problem
wenn ich mein t shirt ausziehen
machen sie das manchmal nicht sehr oft
weil ich normalerweise einen bh tragen
und schnell einen sonnenbrand hätte
gerne hätte ich mit enzmann gesprochen
doch weiter ist der bei meinem besuch
gerade in der hauptstadt
ob sie wirklich integriert ist ist
schwer zu beurteilen
ich versuche es anders was müsste ich
tun um ein mba zu werden damit sie mit
uns leben könnten und ein anderer werden
listen sie eine familie könnten
den tieren beigebracht
für eine von euch heiraten ist nicht
verlobt ist sie da
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
zu vertieften heirats abklärungen fehlt
dann leider die zeit
und so bleiben die mb ram rio san juan
dpa jenny und ich reise weiter konturen
panama dem letzten land in mittelamerika
nach lima südamerika hauptstadt perus
[Musik]
eine hässliche stadt sagen die einen
eine stadt mit rauscharme finde ich
das klima trocken die sonne scheint
selten meist liegt ein streifen nebel
über der küste
die stadt lebt von industrie und
tourismus wichtige branchen wie die
fischerei führen eine randexistenz
freddy goh ag ist einer der letzten
fischer und nimmt mich mit aufs meer
[Musik]
maria führt eines der bekanntesten
fischrestaurants in lima jeden tag fährt
er zum fischen raus freddy macht sich
sorgen
viele waren die sandstrände jetzt ist
alles betoniert für die
schiffsanlegestelle das macht die
brutstätten der fische kabul
früher gab es fischer ohne ende gekommen
ist das ruderboot nehmen und hat es die
nur an empfangen heute will man immer
mehr vermehren
jetzt hat es geantwortet und gibt uns
fast keine fische mehr ein guter fang
ist freddy gradias lebensgrundlage dass
seine lieblings fische ins netz gehen
wird immer seltener
das eine ist der camino und der
schnarcht
dann gibt es denn so puel der sind er
hatte einen bauch indem er die eier
direkt riechen schmecken köstlich
gleich nach dem wissen das ist das
privileg fischer die peruanische küche
gilt derzeit als die innovativste von
südamerika beeinflusst von
eingewanderten chinesen afrikanischen
sklaven und indios freddy war via
bereitet sie wie sie zu den salat as rom
fisch und meer früchten mit limonen
mariniert
freddys tochter sonja die küchenchefin
verrät mir ihr geheimrezept in peru gibt
es viele gemüse und säfte die sehr gut
sind und wichtig für die zubereitung
aber die wichtigste zutat ist die liebe
braucht jeder koch und jede köchin wenn
ein koch schlecht gelaunt ist
funktioniert es nicht
dann ist es besser wenn er frei
natürlich zeigt mir sonja acht das
rezept für das nationalgetränk perus
einen vierten ab gekochten saft aus
getrocknetem höhen klimadaten erhält er
seine dunkle farbe roger moore oder
gehören gewürznelke nani samen zimt und
ananas
[Musik]
die fisch rezepte sind einfach meist
wird der fisch nur im heißen öl
frittiert
freddys restaurant läuft wie geschmiert
das essen ist ein traum ein traum von
fischen die singen und schnarchen in der
nacht
[Musik]
ich verlasse lima und fliege über die
gipfel der peruanischen anden nach süden
mein ziel gusko dreieinhalb tausend
meter über meer näher am himmel als die
meisten städte der welt
die sagenumwobene hauptstadt des inka
reichs in gus komisch sich der prunk der
spanischen eroberer mit der armut der
menschen vom land
[Musik]
alles riecht nach vergangenheit überall
ein blick zurück in der zeit
ich bin auf dem weg nach machu picchu
dem inka heiligtum
es wird abend über cusco ziehen gewitter
auf plötzlich sehe ich zwei männer man
könnte meinen sie seien direkt der inka
zeit entsprungen
es sind schon ahnen bei der götter
beschwörung getrocknete kokablätter
sollen ihnen den kontakt zu
übersinnlichen kräften vermitteln
die begrüßung verläuft überraschend ich
bin in die ana auf land
warum sprechen sie deutsch ich habe
studiert danach bekomme ich hier zum
beitritt in weiterhelfen meine folgt nur
zum erleben
dies hatte aus dem regenwald lebte 25
jahre lang in berlin
denn er verliebte sich in eine deutsche
frau in cusco bewohnt ein armseliges
haus aus stein und lehm im innern eine
russische küche lebensmittelpunkt eines
imkers als dem einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts drei seiner töchter leben
in deutschland und das einer späteren
ehe stammen zwei weitere kinder die ihr
alleine aufzieht in seiner version der
geschichte hat er deutschland verlassen
und kam zurück nach peru
weil er etwas gegen den untergang der
alten kulturen tun will
er habe die geschichte des
südamerikanischen ureinwohner studiert
sagt mir cassis athen seiner kleinen
bibliothek
deswegen muss ich habe die bibel für den
rest seines lebens bleibt der schamanen
cusco die töchter in deutschland in
weiter ferne
natürlich vermisse ich meine töchter
aber ich habe keine möglichkeit sie zu
besuchen hier verdienst du nicht wie in
europa hier lebt man nicht hier überlebt
man nur weil auch hier eine frau fehlt
erledigt der alleinerziehende schamane
neben den religiösen pflichten auch die
profanen dinge des lebens selbst kochen
für die kinder
[Musik]
es braucht nur einige schritte weg von
den touristen faden um zu erkennen wie
einfach und tag das leben in den alten
noch immer ist kam anderswo als in den
zeiten des inka reichs von cuzco nach
machu picchu
fährt man mit dem zug durch das obama
teil
seit tagen hat es geregnet das land ist
grün und fruchtbar
[Musik]
nach zwei stunden fahrt und dem aufstieg
auf 2400 meter legte es vor mir
machu picchu nebelverhangenen und
mystisch und fast ohne besucher ein
wunder der baukunst und machtzentrum der
inka kultur eine kultur die von
kolumbien bis peru halb südamerika
dominierte man geht davon aus dass es
sich um eine tempelanlage handelte eine
festung für die in könige und ihre
priester eine stadt für bis zu 1000
einwohner
doch morgens aufzeichnungen bleibt
vieles spekulation
ein meisterwerk umgeben von senkrechten
felswänden erbaut vor mehr als einem
halben jahrtausend
[Musik]
hier siehst du die röcke herausstehen
und zwischen den blöcken gibt es
einbuchtung so dass die steine verteilt
sind und sozusagen erdbeben fest
zusammen sie haben die steil so lange
geschliffen bisschen vollkommen eben war
die flächen sind so perfekt gearbeitet
dass zwischen den gewaltigen glocken
nicht mal eine nadel hineinpasst das ist
ja unglaublich
ja das ist wirklich erstaunlich damit
zeigen uns die inkas wie fortgeschritten
die technik ihres imperiums war
heute ist die zahl der besucher machu
picchu south 3.000 pro tag beschränkt um
die ausgrabungen zu schützen vor jahren
sollte die anlage privatisiert werden
seilbahnen und helikopter flüge waren
geplant
[Musik]
auf dem höhepunkt der kommerzialisierung
treten kamerateams bierwerbung an
heiligen orten bis sie hier am inn
stewart anna stein ein stück abbrachen
da ging ein aufschrei durch das volk
wollte nicht dass machu picchu
privatisiert wird die einwohner couscous
wehrführer und die agenturen
alle wehrten sich der tourismus ist die
wichtigste einkommensquelle für uns
deshalb sollten wir unser kulturelles
erbe schützen mit mut und
erfindungsgeist schlugen die bauherren
der inka pfad durch schroffe felsen
diese fantastische und
geschichtsträchtige region ist die
heimat meines tour guides melden
weißt du für mich mit in die jugend ist
es eine freude den besuchern die inka
kultur zu erklären wie machu picchu
entstanden ist
ja es gefällt mir sehr ein nachfahre der
inka zu sein
wahrscheinlich wurde machu picchu vor
der eroberung durch die spanier fertig
gebaut wozu bleibt letztlich ungeklärt
auch das macht diesen besuch zu einem
magischen erlebnis
ich verlasse machu picchu und fahre haft
mrt planung der hochebene zwischen peru
und bolivien entlang der panamericana
richtung süden
[Musik]
ankunft in la paz der wichtigsten stadt
boliviens und regierungssitz auf 4000
meter über meer hoch über der stadt
leben die alten bauern von der output
sucht die wolle ist begehrt die tiere
aus der familie der kamele sind zäh und
widerstandsfähig kokablätter kahns
erklärt mir der hirte in einigen brocken
sein leben
das sind die tiere die uns das leben
ermöglichen sie geben es zu essen geld
sie geben uns alle
die wolle ist der grund weshalb sich
noble damen wie die modedesignerin
vertriebskanäle patiño hier hinauf
bemühen um mit den bauern ihre geschäfte
abzuschließen
gerne möchte sie mir die alpakawolle
zeigen dann müssen sie ein tier
einfangen sagt der bauer maliziös
[Musik]
die näheren schneidereien in la paz
beschäftigt beatrix kiddo patiño über 50
angestellte und exportiert in 13 ländern
sie ist die berühmteste modedesignerin
boliviens hillary clinton und die
spanische königin gehören zu ihren
kundinnen und kultur für die weltspitze
mit stoff aus den anden was ist das
perfekte kleid als apk wolle für eine
frau für mich heißt sinnlichkeit nicht
dass die frau nur halb bekleidet ist
oder viel haut zeigt nun eine frau kann
sich wie eine nonne kleiden und doch
sehr sinnlich sein
das liegt eine frau selbst für mich
machen nicht die kleider die frauen
sondern die frauen die kleider die
modekönigin ist 60 jahre alt und
sprudelt vor energie 2000 dollar kosten
solche stücke in new york hier sind es
immerhin gegen 600 ich bin verblüfft
dass sich die dicken parka rolle eignet
für die rote tür
seit 25 jahren weiß ich dass kamelien
fasern einen leichten weichen sinnlich
in den luxuriösen und reichhaltigen
stoff ist so anpassungsfähig dass ich
meine entwürfe perfekt an die model
schmieren als beatrice kanäle patiño 13
jahre alt war zog sie nach new york und
später nach paris
auf dem höhepunkt ihrer karriere gehörte
sie zu den top design rennen der
internationalen szene
doch dann kehrte sie heim von der
seventh avenue nach bolivien ein
überraschender schritt
das ist mein land
ich bin in la paz geboren ich bin so
stolz dass ich diese stücke in die ganze
welt exportieren kann und sie sind made
in bolivien
ich will zeigen dass wir aus bolivien
heraus und gut höhe exportieren können
diesen beweis muss beatrice kann eto'o
patiño für mich nicht mehr antreten
eines der ärmsten länder südamerikas hat
in ihr eine schillernde botschafterin
des guten geschmacks
das quäntchen mondänes leben findet
außerhalb der hauptstadt la paz schnell
ein ende
[Musik]
ein paar eisenbahnlinien verbinden
einige wenige städte ein exil ist
juni die reise zum salzsee damals sieben
stunden
[Musik]
der zug reist espresso und der süd
express ruckelt mit 40 kilometern pro
stunde durch bolivien dem
höchstgelegenen land südamerikas einsame
hochebenen und grandiose landschaften
[Musik]
kein land hat mehr menschen mit
indianischen wurzeln aus bolivien
vielleicht ist darf dass ein teil seiner
exotik
[Musik]
der nächste morgen hält eine
überraschung bereit
das hotel in dem ich übernachtet habe
ist das salz gebaut und trägt einen
unbescheidenen namen balancity salz
passt die junge chefin ist stolz auf
diese mischung aus modernem design und
verblüffender bausubstanz und weit mich
in ihr geheimnis ein
aber wenn ich küchen salz mit wasser
mischen kann ich nicht wirklich ein haus
bauen oder hier gibt es natürlich eine
menge salz will man es mit der richtigen
menge wasser mischt kann man damit bauen
aber küchen salz geht nicht denn es
enthält jod und würde nicht richtig hat
unser salz ist sehr fein im ohne judt
früher übernachteten die touristen hier
am salzsee von uyuni draußen im zelt bei
temperaturen bis minus 20 grad
deswegen erwarten ihre eltern das hotel
an diesem einsamen ort
auch in den hotels seemann ist alles
salz das kannst du abbrechen keine angst
das ist nur salz weit und breit keine
anderen häuser nur unendlichkeit die
absolute ruhe
das genießen die besucher am meisten vor
allem wenn sie aus großen städten kommen
wie bei euch
[Musik]
eigentlich läge hier ein ausgetrocknetes
beta salz doch das salz liegt unter
wasser nachdem es einige wochen lang
geregnet hat
[Musik]
der salar de uyuni in bolivien ist der
größte salzsee der welt eine unwirkliche
sphärische szenerie
[Musik]
glas als türmen sich auf stehen in reih
und glied wie zeichen an unbekannte
wesen dessen salzburger die zum trocknen
errichtet werden
[Musik]
tag für tag scharfen cavani und seine
mitarbeiter das salzhaff ihre alten trox
sie sind nur schlechter ausgerüstet mit
mützen gegen not von und sonnenbrand auf
traditionelle weise wird das salz
gesammelt getrocknet mitgemischt und zu
kochsalz verarbeitet ein paar dutzend
familien leben davon
wie ist die arbeit schwer und hart
das aufladen ist anstrengend aber sie
scheinen es sich gewöhnt das mache ich
schon seit ich klein war
seit sie klein war ja schon als kind mit
zehn fangen wir an zu arbeiten weil der
schlüssel nicht mehr funktioniert
schließt er die zündung mit zwei kabeln
kurz
heute arbeiteten die kinder nur noch am
wochenende sagte
ich staune dass die männer noch immer
von hand schaffen wäre es mit maschinen
nicht einfacher nein dass es nicht
einfacher weil mit dem salz dann auch
dreck mit kommt mit der schaufel nehmen
wir nur das als die oberste schicht
was seit jahrhunderten so gemacht wurde
ändert sich nicht so schnell
[Musik]
vom salzsee geht es auf die letzte
etappe in bolivien 300 kilometer
schotterpiste
unter dieser erde liegen wertvolle
rohstoffe ihre ausbeutung steht erst am
anfang
wir überqueren den höchsten pass auf
5000 meter
ich habe das gefühl dass der planet erst
gerade geboren wurde ein gay's schlamm
köpfen schwefelgeruch sticht in die nase
[Musik]
und dann erreichen wir das ziel die
laguna colorada an der grenze zu chile
umringt von den gipfeln der karriere
durch eine seltene algenart rot gefärbt
erhielt die lagune ihrem namen
es ist kaum zu fassen dass ich hier wo
keine zeichen von leben zu sehen sind
auf hunderte von flamingos stoßen
[Musik]
ich folge der panamericana weiter nach
argentinien dem letzten land dieser
reise sein orden des riesigen landes ist
isoliert und wenig besiegelt es ist das
land der großen farmen hier in der
provinz corrientes liegen die
ursprünglichsten und am weitesten
abgelegenen es transfers von argentinien
san juan dpa ist eine klassische form
seit generationen in familienbesitz
die besitzer und der chefcoach für mich
ein
nach alter sitte fangen sie die tiere
noch mit dem lasso ein
was aussieht wie ein großes gaudi ist
knochenarbeit 3000 rinder wert geimpften
mit einem spray gegen parasiten
geschützt
[Musik]
mit dem lassen können wir mitten im feld
mit einer kuh arbeiten sie von der herde
trennen sagt markieren kastrieren und
von parasiten befreien
du kannst die ganze herde beobachten an
einem ort können wir so über 100 kühe
pflegen die wirtschaftlichen bedingungen
für die fahrer sind härter geworden
[Applaus]
markus verkauft seine tiere sobald sie
aufgezogen sind denn hier in der savanne
ist das land nicht besonders fruchtbar
heute prüft er welche für trächtig sind
nicht richtig
keine besonders angenehme aufgabe
jemand muss es tun nicht wahr
so geht es am einfachsten innerhalb des
kaders nicht richtig aber man muss
wissen wie die gauchos verrichten ihre
arbeit wie eh und je
tragen sie keine schuhe barfuß spürte
die steigbügel besser das gibt die mehr
sicherheit auf dem pferd
es ist bequemer ohne schuhe vor allem
wenn es heiß ist und sind sie jeden tag
barfuß ja außer wenn es sehr kalt ist
habs anfahren der polo arbeiten die
gauchos praktisch in lebensstellung
viele sind familienväter und wohnen in
der umgebung
wenn die arbeit zu ende ist sitzen sie
am feuer und trinken masse den bitteren
südamerikanischen t
es sind knorrige freundliche männer und
der neugierige fragen stellt muss mit
schlagfertigen antworten rechnen
und als ich habe arbeite ich schon hier
und warum immer am selben ort weil mich
der chef nicht entlässt
ich sehe auch gut aus attraktive kerle
wie wir werden nicht entlassen ich bin
der beste er
pedro der chef coach arbeitet seit 37
jahren auf distanz ja jeden tag reitet
er von zu hause mit dem pferd anderthalb
stunden hin und zurück hat er nie daran
gedacht ein auto zu kaufen
auf diese idee kenne ich nie gefehlt
gegen ein auto oder motorrad an thorsten
autos haben pannen ein pferd geht nie
kaputt
[Musik]
es ist ein erhebendes gefühl hoch zu
ross einiges san juan dpa hof erinnert
an das leben von land art liegen
[Musik]
für das ist ja ein gewaltiges kapital da
sind sie sicher ein reicher mann oder
nein ich bin überhaupt kein reicher mann
wenn man 3000 kühe hat braucht man eine
menge personal und der presse hier wird
von den politikern bestimmt
in den letzten fünf sechs jahren machte
ich nur gewinnen
dieses land konnte mit dem was es im
vergangenen jahr produzierte nicht
einmal die löhne des personals hat die
steuern bezahlen
abends wenn die pferde gewaschen und
gebürstet sind wird gemeinsam gegessen
18 gauchos arbeiten auf der farm und ra
köchinnen es gibt keinen elektrischen
strom nur bei dunkelheit läuft ein
generator im esszimmer des hausherrn ist
heute der sohn mit zwei freunden zu
besuch
markus der besitzer ist geschieden sein
sohn lebt in der hauptstadt buenos aires
willkommene abwechslung in der
abgeschiedenheit nicht verheiratet zu
sein bedeutet nicht keine beziehung zu
haben
längere oder aufgezogen es ist nicht
einfach für eine frau die ihr aufs land
zu ziehen
es braucht jemanden der sich selber
beschäftigen kann
immerhin haben wir jetzt fernsehen und
einen generator und ich hoffe auch dass
wir bald eine stromleitung bekommen
federico der sohn studiert jura
oft sind es heute anwälte und ärzte die
sich noch eine instanz ja leisten können
[Musik]
und während pedro seinem
anderthalbstündigen ritt nach hause
antritt
zach ich weiter und hoffe dass mein auto
keine panne hat es sind 1000 kilometer
bis zum nächsten ziel von loretto im
corrientes in die hauptstadt buenos
aires
dass argentinien vor zehn jahren
parcours zwar spürt man kaum mehr die
stadt pulsiert und wegen der vielen
museen und theater heißt buenos aires
auch das paris südamerikas die großen
einwanderungsbewegungen anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts aus italien
england und frankreich zeigen die
stimmung
buenos aires ist eine stadt zwischen
schwermut und hochgefühl liebe tango und
neurosen hawk eye ist der bekannteste
schriftsteller und psychiater der stadt
quasi ein experte für die argentinische
seelenlage
[Musik]
buenos aires liberal ein magnet für die
homosexuellen pokal bringt dies zugleich
in einen zusammenhang mit dem tango
argentinien hat ihr nie wirklich etwas
gegen homosexuelle
vielleicht wegen des tangos du weißt
dass der tango ursprünglich von männern
getanzt wurde
es war ein tanz zwischen zwei männern
nicht etwa ein frauen tanz man sagt das
kommt davon dass in den anfängen des
tangos kam frauen abends ausgegangen
seien
laböck geist wohl der farbigsten
stadtteil von buenos aires früher
geprägt durch die italiener heute ein
mix aus afrikanischen spanischen und
kubanischen kulturen an jeder ecke wird
tango getanzt
[Musik]
ist er teil war eine macho sache der
mann formuliert die frau ordnet sich
unter nein nicht beim richtigen tag
wir sehen es bei diesem paar es ist
nicht der mann der entscheidet sondern
eröffnet den raum ist für die frau und
sie entscheidet wie sie sich ins team
das ist der schlüssel zum tanken viele
tango paare verwechseln darf
es ist eine sache von beiden so weit die
meinung des spezialisten zur
psychoanalyse des tangos
ganz in der nähe finde ich dass
schneider atelier von florin dobrindt
sie der sich seit 42 jahren auf tango
kostüme spezialisiert hat brände sie ist
83 und seine schaffenskraft ungebrochen
außer jünger war tanzte florindo den
tango mit seiner frau in den schönsten
lokalen von buenos aires damals um zum
tango zu denen krawatte hemd und anzug
gut rasiert und mit geputzten schuhen
gingen wir damals zum tanken
du musst es präsentabel sei am eingang
schalten sie uns von oben bis unten an
wenn du keine krawatte hat es tut mir
leid da musstest du nach hause um eine
anzuziehen
auch in anderer hinsicht haben sich die
zeiten geändert
zwar war der tanz freizügig die sitten
waren es nicht
das charmante in dieser zeit war das ein
mädchen nie alleine ging immer war die
mutter dabei und die mutter schaute dass
die burschen ihr nicht zu nahe kamen
wenn das passiert sagte die mutter mit
dem kannst du nicht mehr der drückt
nicht zu fest an sich
[Gelächter]
vielleicht ist diese nostalgische
strenge mit ein grund weshalb der tanker
heute in den zeiten des 11 ingos wieder
hochkonjunktur hat
[Musik]
hier
juni
ok
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das letzte stück dieser reise entlang
der panamericana durch zwei kontinente
führt mich von buenos aires an die
südspitze nach osch feiern
die südlichste stadt der welt ist
ausgangspunkt für reisen in die
antarktis
während bei uns der frühling beginnt
wird es im schweier winter im juli
herrscht eine temperatur von
durchschnittlich minus zwei grad
auch das ist argentinien
[Musik]
vorgeblich lebt vom tourismus aus karten
fischer beliefert er die restaurants von
schweier mit einem kleinen fischkutter
sticht woche einmal pro woche in see
meist ist das wetter stürmisch nicht
ungefährlich und das raue klima hat die
menschen von nur schweier geprägt
unabhängig und ab sich selber gestellt
so sehen sie sich selbst
in einem notfall wenn ich mir nicht mehr
selber helfen kann wenn etwas kaputt ist
der motor oder wenn sonst etwas schief
geht dann müsste ich die küstenwache
rufen aber ehrlich gesagt lieber sterbe
ich dass ich mich von der küstenwache
retten lassen die küstenwache es die
letzte warum argentinien hat sie viel
bürokratie die produktivität
interessiert sind nur immer mehr
bürokratie
[Musik]
doch liebling begann als mechaniker
später entwickelte er eigene karten
netze und so fängt er heute die größten
tiere von schweier
der ist 14 jahre alt und wie man sie
trifft durch sollen menschen wie siehst
du das
etwa 200 kilo
eigentlich woche in einer wärmeren
gegend auf doch hier in der schweiz gebe
es viel arbeit sagt er
ein leben reduziert darf existenzielle
tatsachen nüchtern ist auch die
einstellung des karten fischers zu
seinem fall besonders schöne exemplare
sparte für die restaurants alle anderen
werden zerlegt er will die fischen geht
und die fische liegen herum dann
ersticken sie die sterben lebt ist es
tut das handwerk im schweier argentinien
und so endet diese reise am ende der
welt sind feuer und diarra del fuego
alaska liegt 20.000 kilometer entfernt
damals hatte sich der winter gerade
verabschiedet hier steht er wieder vor
der tür
was aber ist das fazit dieses großen
abenteuers man jagt den sehnsüchten nach
die man ihn sich trägt seit man ein kind
war
doch seltenheit sich die realität an die
vorstellungen die man sich von ihr macht
im schlimmsten und im schönsten wurden
meine erwartungen unendlich übertroffen
was bleibt sind unglaubliche
landschaften und magische orte und
menschen die zwar vollkommen fremd waren
und doch durch ihre wärme fast zu
freunden wurden
dass diese momente so zahlreich waren
macht die bahn amerikaner für mich für
immer unvergesslich
[Musik]